six-time Pro Bowler longtime friend of
this program he was way back in the day
on the podcast he is one of the best
running backs of his day and the
question is is uh you know we got more
days to come his name is LeSean McCoy
how are you doing LaShawn hey first of
all you know you're one of my favorites
you know that so right man right back at
you LeSean McCoy and and I understand
you know one of the reason why I'm your
favorite is and you could be honest
please be honest with me LaShawn is that
you've seen my work at the combine and
you're jealous you're jealous of the
speed and you'd love oh right I want
think jealous but I actually I'm a big
fan of like how consistent you're no
matter how slow the time is you always
try to get better and better and that's
the problem to leak anymore guys like
you do you know what I appreciate that
compliment I take offense at the word
slow you know you could use the word
fast in the sentence still means the
same thing
LaShawn well not enough guys in the
league would try to stay consistent try
and stay at the same level right LeSean
that's what you're saying
right right and that's one thing you're
consistent you try to get better every
every time you run at forty no matter
the outcome or the results off the cliff
you know I mean lucky ticket right up to
the right up to the edge and it goes
right off he basically all due respected
you oh my gosh which is fine I mean you
might have I don't know might be two
guys is keeping keeping time on the
timer
some guys and you might go check them
okay no jerking you around or what but
what's the fastest forty you right um
like high school all that stuff doesn't
really count you know now that you have
all the I think they combine for young
kids right but I would say well four
four four
what's number four four five was the
official at the combine honeycomb
Indianapolis yeah well you didn't run it
that I ramped up
oh so you ran it he ran it in did you
run it
where was the protein was it in Heinz
Field was that pro day in Heinz Field or
no no it was all in the inside so else
okay so at Heinz Field when you were
around Heinz Field did you see an
envelope with the name James Harrison on
it anywhere lashauwn yeah and you have
you heard this story about what James
Harrison said am I breaking news to you
oh my oh my gosh oh well I do this when
I was there and he was there yes he was
a scary looking man so you're a pet
Panther and there's James Harrison
strolling around right Archie we play
the sound bite for LeSean McCoy
we're like breaking history so yeah this
you remember that hit epod on Mohammed
Massaquoi 2010 you remember that one
okay that was brought up to him on a
podcast called going deep on barstool
and this is wild I mean this has gone
crazy
and so it's kind of crazy that I'm
bringing this breaking this news to you
but this is what he had to say go for
most you've ever been find the one game
one game was 75 listen everything I love
oh my dad is great I hit that man
without backs 50% of what I had and I
just hit him because I wanted him to let
loose in the ball if I had new things go
find me 75,000 I would have tried to
kill him
[Laughter]
75 wait for every night I - I don't lie
to you what I happen right genius thing
Mike Tana ever did he handed me a meal
oh god today I'm gonna say what he had
to be in look like today
how about that JD he said Mike Talman
gave him an envelope it was the Jesus
thing Tomlin's ever done as he gave him
an envelope
won't say what's in it but he just left
it at that okay okay I get it I get what
happened okay wow that's crazy
I promise you if I didn't all my might
like that's scared you have you ever
heard of a coach handing a somebody an
envelope to defray the cost of a fine or
anything like that have you ever heard
anything like that LaShawn nah not like
that but depend on flair depend on the
situation a lot of guys would ship in
you know and uh kinda help out so the
players would chip in and help out but
not the coaches like nah my comms
especially dude though
so that's believable you know he's alone
God that he does whatever for his
players so I could see him doing that no
kidding hit Lee and the linemen their
fight and all that a fight for him right
and their chip in and take care that
fine especially the quarterback they got
all the money
so let's sean mccoy here on the Rich
Eisen show what's the hardest you've
ever been hit who's the hardest
anybody's ever hit you Wow I don't we
played at that game like that you know
you got a I only let nobody hit me about
my game I'm sorry think you know what we
won song I played the the rescue this is
one of London's lecture he was he was
part of hard player everyone against
blind beggar heaven on what the dude
that was all juiced up hello stairways
big safety um he had the muscles in his
neck and his ears hit the muscle in his
fingers that was his name
LaRon Landry right so once all he caught
me in the wrist and he probably used his
piece 230 230 plus the steroids that
makes him prior to 45 he got me in the
rich boy oh my god you broke my ribs
and I'm I came out like okay my ribs
broke cuz reason what you gonna do and I
pitched the game you know that that was
probably harder hit so Andy's like what
you gonna do is he's basically like the
times yours essentially yes what he said
listen in a critical time of the games
he'll he's jokes all the time and I'll
come with only I think I put my wrist
he look named like well what you gonna
do you know play or not you know messing
with me so what do you mean he's funny
what are
really yeah oh my god this time man and
like I'm not even issue um I had some
good plays and and I came out the game
he's are you planning that claim early
Sean Courtney not was something cool and
walked off you know just to mess with me
so I get back out there I can a Mac hit
this remember mad times where he met
small players you know like during a
critical time of the game joke a little
you know but that's what makes us
special
yeah never a big never a moment a big
long right and boy you were through
thick and thin through all those moments
in Philadelphia obviously towards the
end and then now this year where Andy
Reid is finally called a Super Bowl
winning head coach you are a Super Bowl
winner yourself and you mentioned LeSean
McCoy here in the Rich Eisen show you
know you're gonna play you're not are
you gonna play what do you what's your
future yeah well that's a couple teams
I'm looking at um I told some things
that I wouldn't know I guess
entertaining some of the offers because
I want like the right fit right my
career has been very solid you know I
want to go out on the right foot I want
to I want to play with a good team a
winning team gonna play with all some
good young backs to teach him you know
showing the ropes a little bit maybe
peonies and leadership help out in that
area but I don't want to go from winning
the Super Bowl to play on the team is
just I mean just just playing you know
fans
I thought done so much in league for
that you said the word solid we I I
don't know this was the word solid to me
is not it's not a very complimentary
word to me you know I you know I mean to
use solid your six-time Pro Bowler
two-time first-team all-pro you led the
league in rushing one year you're
rushing touchdowns at the all decades
team 2010 what's it what's what's his
numbers for he's all decade we had the
decade and rushing yards second
touchdown yeah kind of the smart little
bit okay well alright just like what's
for tea time we are similar we are
similar
although I you know I I joined the
league in 2003 you joined it in 2009 and
so you plan on playing the 2020 season
we have a playing season that's gonna be
2020 that's right have you heard
anything about what protocols are gonna
be set up in terms of player health and
safety and the virus if you as anybody
reached out to you or you aware of
anything that that's police it up it
well there's - home is always like I
guess rumors are thoughts right my pains
you know it's a big possibility we might
be playing was limited same right
I got 70,000 things you probably get
10,000 if that spreads of spreads around
right um it's tough I mean you didn't
talk about like so upstairs might
already came like go home you know it's
like the families that stay in hotels so
zombies it's different I guess on
thoughts about it so we'll see fill up
in the air okay well I hope you got want
to see you out there on the field this
fall the Sean I want to see you try you
know how many how many more usually
figure out left you know what I always
have to put a number on it and one of my
good friends
I call him my OG Frank good you can't go
how your body feels and if his body
feels good every year so who knows well
I mean just you you're you're five years
younger than him and he's out there
right now I mean he's amazing
that guy is amazing and we're trying to
go into this like this is the way he
trained smart how does he drink yeah I
love the game two o'clock and play
that's not always a different role what
what is it like training with him what's
it like training with Franklin you know
stuff like on determine all the younger
guys he says he times Jared irons so
that he can keep up you don't have to
beat him but he keep up with that lets
him know he still can play and all the
time I'm I I'm just trying to beat him
cuz I only look at the younger you know
fighters trying to chase me but everyone
has the only thing they drive LaShawn I
appreciate the time man I miss chatting
with you when we'll get you back on in
the next couple weeks you sign with
somebody I want you on let's talk about
it okay let's do it
it's always good
no doubt man right back at you you take
care of the Shawn you be well that's the
sean mccoy at cut on dime at 25 and at
shady McCoy that's is Twitter and
Instagram accounts
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here